let's talk about magnets and magnetic
forces
magnets are these neat objects that are
able to attract metals like iron
magnets are used in all sorts of things
from holding paper on your refrigerator
to computers two compasses
so magnets can be used to stick things
together point us in the right direction
and even lift things
and they do this through magnetic forces
if you've handled two magnets you felt
magnetic forces even when the magnets
weren't touching each other that's
because magnetic forces are non-contact
forces which just means they can affect
other objects they aren't even touching
magnets will attract or
repel each other and this attraction or
repulsion is a magnetic force
but magnetic forces don't affect
everything the same way otherwise a
magnet would stick to you not just a
refrigerator
in this video we're going to talk about
the magnetic forces between two magnets
so why do magnets sometimes attract each
other and other times repel each other
well this has to do with the orientation
of the magnets
orientation is really just a fancy word
for how the magnets are positioned
compared to one another
you see it turns out that each magnet
has a north and a south pole
but what does this have to do with
attraction or repulsion
well as you may have heard opposites
attract so if you face the north pole of
one magnet to the south pole of another
magnet guess what
they will be attracted to each other
but if you turn one of those magnets
around so that you have two north poles
facing each other they will repel
and the same thing would happen if it
was two south poles facing each other
so the direction of the magnetic force
completely depends on the orientation of
the magnets
orientation though is just one thing
that affects magnetic forces the
strength of magnetic forces depends on a
couple of things
for one
distance
if you've ever held two magnets you may
have noticed that when you move them
closer they seem to almost jump together
or if you try to push two like poles
together they get harder and harder to
hold together the closer you get
this is because magnetic forces depend
on distance
the closer the two magnets are together
the stronger the force between them so
as the distance decreases the force
increases
but the farther away they are the weaker
the magnetic force is
so
distance increases force decreases
the other big factor that affects how
strong a magnetic force is well the
magnets themselves submagnets are really
weak like a lot of refrigerator magnets
others are so strong that even tiny ones
can be almost impossible to pull apart
some of these stronger magnets are even
used to make high-speed trains levitate
off the ground
and yes this rectangle is supposed to be
a train
while my drawing isn't amazing the fact
that magnetic forces can levitate a
train
is